when you take your sensitivity to the
internet
based off your perception and you
weaponize
against someone yeah without giving you
give me an example
what a example would be like you know
taylor swift okay so she's now upset
that a show made a joke about her oh
yeah
netflix show yeah this netflix they made
it so she tweeted so she tweeted out
yeah she tweeted out like this is lazy
writing and you know she made it like
she made herself the victim in this
situation
and it's like it's like damn so she took
her 100 million followers
and she has an army of people she has a
[ __ ] man
and it's like swift if anybody can take
a joke it should be
the people in the public eye like that
yeah yeah like
it's it should be easy that should be
lightworked
and the joke was like the two characters
are talking to the the ladies said
she says um oh you go through more men
than twilight taylor swift
shannon lyon the thing is
it's not even about that the point is
it's like so then to like weaponize
her sensitivity yes on her twitter i
think it's irresponsible yeah
i think it's irresponsible i feel like
it's unfair or even like it's like
it just happened to me in phoenix i have
joke i'm working at these jokes man
i have been on stage in a year i'm
working out i'm not making excuses
because
even if you say something that somebody
gets hurt it's like okay but i feel like
in my mind i'm making a good point and i
and i feel like i'm coming from a good
place i don't have ill intent
you know and like one of us do when we
go up there but like i said
there's gonna be a butt of every joke
and sometimes that butt gets slapped
and people don't like that some people
do some people don't
and i get it so you made somebody upset
she tweets about it you know
what what was the topic just about
transgender it doesn't even matter you
know they just i was really upset and
hurt and it was hurtful and bold
and i got my initial reaction i was like
[ __ ] you yeah you know what i mean
like you didn't hear what i said you
know what i mean yeah but that's that
person's perception but again
no details now people that weren't even
there what an [ __ ]
i can't believe this yeah meanwhile that
was one person
one [ __ ] that's how it takes but
they're what i'm saying is you're
valid to have your feelings i'm okay
with you being upset
and i can even be like you know what
there's two times you should apologize
to people
all right when you do wrong and if
someone's hurt by something that you did
whether you meant to do wrong or not so
i can sit here now and be like
she was hurt by what i said and i and i
can be like i apologize that you were
hurt by that
okay i'm sorry that you were hurt by
that i'm working this out
and now i see a different perspective
actually because afterwards i was like
mad and i'm looking at the jokes and i'm
thinking about him
and then i'm like well maybe if somebody
could see it this way so i need to be
more clear in how i do this joke that's
all it is so so i'm working it out but
damn for you to make it now that you
characterizing me as a monster
because of your sensitivity and your
perception anti-transgender
that's what chemical culture is correct
yeah to make someone a monster
yeah so cancel culture becomes this
thing where like without details without
first-hand knowledge without
you're gonna take that sensitivity and
you're going to weaponize it
and i just find that that is i i think
it doesn't move us forward
it doesn't move us forward i mean
conversations are what moves us forward
i mean
and it's like all i say to people that
come to comedy shows or you're talking
about comedians
let's assume good intentions first
before anything yes they're [ __ ] yes
there are people clearly trying to be
mean
but let's assume i don't have ill intent
i'm just working this out especially in
my mind because i'm saying like the
whole point of it is to be like
we shouldn't normalize this it shouldn't
matter we shouldn't care about this as
much as we do
now within that i'm gonna have jokes
because i go after both sides
i don't care like my favorite compliment
is when a republican conservative person
comes up to me after my show and goes
yeah thanks for talking about both sides
you know and they're not saying to me
why'd you do jokes about conservatives
they're going thanks for joking about
them too
yeah you say everybody get everybody
everybody get it
and my thing is like don't you want to
feel normal don't you want to be like
you're at a show and no matter who you
are you going to get it yeah you're good
you're you're you're you're a part of
what i feel like because i don't i don't
look i hate when people
assume my intent yeah yeah don't assume
that don't
don't assume my internet don't assume
i'm telling you what my intent is now if
i didn't achieve that
if i because you know what the real
issue is we're not as brilliant as we
think we are
people aren't as articulate as they
think they are even right now people are
misconstruing what we're saying or
they're taking what they want from it
it's actually harder than you think to
articulate your point
and that's why when you're a comic you
have to work on your act
many many times that's why we go up so
much and it's like in this situation
that wasn't a special that it's for
public consumption been on stage in a
year
can we just have this moment in this
crowd just right here can we have this
moment
maybe hit me up privately like i didn't
like what you said yeah then i could be
like
well [ __ ] you and then we go back and
forth and i go you know what you're
right
yeah because my mistake was i tweeted
back and then other people jumped in
this guy's like you're
what an [ __ ] for responding like this
and i said you weren't even there you
weren't even there
and then he goes well you just keep
talking everything you write you know
what i said back to him i was like
you know what you're right i said you
killed them offline i said i said you're
right
because i'm just upset man you know i
don't i'm upset by this unfair
characterization that's what i wrote
back didn't hear from that [ __ ]
again yeah
put him on mute you know he was i mean
everybody anyway because i was like oh i
made a mistake if you were saying
anything because
you know if like you tell me man man i
went to this place
and everybody's getting on me whatever
and then like we can what they getting
on you now all i can believe is you
i i i could be but then i come to find
out you know you were being a dick
well now you have detail you
cancel culture is lack of details
you know and even these details that
they think they get they think well i
got details they said in the story
where's the proof yeah you know can we
see it all first
and then go all right now i'll make a
comment on all of it let's make a
comment on this
now but we don't wait for that and then
it runs amok
can't focus out of hand and there's no
putting the two
toothpaste back in the bottle right once
it's out then it's just like and like i
say again
i have no problem anymore i don't mind
that this generation is sensitive
we're all what i realize is we're all
sensitive sensitive most entertainers
are
and athletes are and you know what else
i realized too
it's cancelled culture or sensitivity
it's always been here
they just now have an outlet they have a
platform they have a platform yeah
before they had to write letters yeah
you know
eddie murphy would talk about it anytime
he did a show he he'd read about it in
the newspaper or something
really that's how it would be so now
people have their own voice so i guess i
realized like george carlin would have
got it
he would have been god okay just because
he was
he had these opinions you know what i
mean there would be people that would be
like
you are so insensitive you know what i
mean so you just go so i get it so i
just feel like it's like it's unfair you
know what i mean
and at the same time fear another side
look taylor swift is upset
you know i get it she's like damn my
business always got to be the butt of
every [ __ ] joke
you know what i mean do i have you know
so she was mad about that all right
i i'm with you nobody wants to be the
butt of a joke
see the butt of the joke got slapped
that's the ass okay she got slapped
but she clapped back in a way that's
like damn
you don't take you like that's a weapon
major one it's a major weapon it's like
that time
she's abusing her power it's like that
time bieber
you know put somebody's phone number
like uh or or something like
it's like if bieber goes uh these people
this look what this person said about me
189 million people now or whatever
they're seeing
whatever the truth is like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
how dare you leave him alone that's a
danger that's like
that's a dangerous weapon you know but
we don't even realize it until you're
like because
even i would do that you know when
somebody says some [ __ ] about you and
you go
look at this troll boom and then your
fans are like troll
do patrol [ __ ] they light them
up you know what i mean
and that's like you know it's like you
don't even realize the the
the power that that wields and someone
like taylor swift she's got a national
platform
she's got so many followers she's got
doctoral communities she's worldwide so
she tweets something the world
looks she knows what's gonna happen yeah
that's what i'm saying she's not like
what's she
she's a smart girl she might have been
at home like i'm [ __ ] them
i'm a watch well she's like i'm sick of
this
yeah watch this and again by the way
more power to you
but like you know don't be like lazy
writing you know
you have songs that are like i will
never ever ever
shakespeare you know what i mean yeah so
but again but again i get it you know
and i'm saying it's like
we just don't realize the extent of how
far we could go
with yeah with with this ingredient it's
like you you get the fact that the
person has that emotion like that
yeah that's your feeling it's like yeah
because yeah anytime someone talks just
to us like
online yeah you feel it you're like
you're like me oh [ __ ] so what i'm
saying is taylor i felt it
but it would be like you guys coming on
your part because i do this on my
podcast sometimes yeah this guy
was talking about like his kid and this
is the third time i'm talking about how
mad i am about it
you know what i mean so i'm actually
doing what i said you know people should
do
i'm doing it right you got to unleash it
[ __ ] i don't understand but i
hear about it you're not like
99. this is an example of the kind of
thing so the guy like he you know
he first and he writes a comment and
calls my girl stupid
oh oh wow you know and so i said you
know i was like yo dude do you think
this is okay
like this is not okay you know you know
this somebody i care about on instagram
you're like you think it's cool
on youtube
[Applause]
but then the guy writes me back like
well you know mike we i was watching you
game i'm a fan and my son sent you a
super chat which is like tip you know
and then he asked to play with you and
then you said
why would i play with you you know now
out of context it's like
you know i'm like yeah when i'm playing
i'm like you know how many people hit me
up to play
likewise like i'm i'm talking about it's
just non-stop messages like here's my
here's my activision id i want to play
call of duty with you but i can't play
with everybody
i don't know you yeah that's what i'm
saying why would i play with you i don't
know you
[Laughter]
i'm not talking about that i'm just
saying i don't know it's a little kid
but if you watch me all the time you get
my sentiment
my sentiment is like come on y'all i
can't play with all y'all now if the kid
was upset if
it came across rude to this individual i
get it i'm sorry all right
i didn't mean for you to be hurt by my
dismissal but also
two dollars you think two dollars means
you own my time now
you think you're buying me for yeah yeah
you got two dollars like oh damn
yeah yeah it's like yeah [ __ ] yeah he
does think that we sent you two dollars
so
what i'm saying is like so this guy
again people take their perception
their perspective and then they attack
you were you guys cool though
and i haven't heard from him since
because i know he's seen me talk about
this now and he must be
he must get because i let him know it's
like yeah i think your bad parenting is
really what's going on right now
letting your kids feel like oh yeah you
can buy whatever you want yeah everybody
you want some firearms send that
[ __ ]
so what i'm saying is like you know
again i get sensitive
taylor swift was sensitive she was mad
she was probably looking at your show
she was trying to watch this new show oh
girl power it's girls you know national
women's month
you know and she's like going for it and
then she sees this joke
you know she's in her palatial palace
and her like california king
you know what i mean there's two asian
boys fan her yeah you know what i'm
saying
they're just asian boys she's still just
fanning her like this you know what i
mean
there's like you know somebody's doing
her nails whatever and she's just
sitting there with all her money and
everything and she's like
[ __ ] them yep unleash the fury [ __ ] them
you know what hit the nuke
and she's a celebrity you know what i
mean she has the most
engagement interaction with her fans
yeah and she's super she's great
so she's great that way you know like
you you have and that's what's great
about see this is how the the internet
we can that's why i hope they never get
rid of it it's because the positive
is of it you could be a fan of taylor
swift yeah and there could be a chance
that she goes
hey what's up yeah yeah and you're live
it's cool yeah yeah
yeah i had to get the [ __ ] out of here
i'm even on a small level whatever it is
i listen i remember meeting bieber
you know at uh the laugh factory and he
took a picture of us
you know he took a picture and he put it
on his instagram you know and i said
well can i
could you tag me man he was like all
right and i said let me do it for you
and then i was doing this phone but he
was so cautious with his phone i
remember he would
he was going to grab it because he was
like get it because i was going to let
me see these dick pics
i don't know what he thought i knew what
he thought i was going to look at
but then like he um you know and then he
tagged me and then my phone
blew up for six months yeah like i had
to turn the notifications off because i
was like
damn oh [ __ ]
you know and then i was getting messages
too i was getting messages from like
young girls like can you
can you tell justin can you just tell
justin that
uh by the way young boys too boy's gonna
be up to like oh yes i i
need him you know what i'm saying wow
nuts like i mean that's like you know
the power is
it was like last night me and my girl
watching that billy eilish doc have you
seen that is that good have you seen it
yeah i watched it it's [ __ ] good it's
good you're a huge fan of her
after you've seen it it was so [ __ ]
good
her mom and like brother did a bunch of
like just normal camera [ __ ] like it's
not like
hd like it's like the dad with the
camera when they're kids
it's dope man but you you she doesn't
talk about it's not on her instagram but
during all this like when she's just
starting to blow like blow the [ __ ] up
when all those you know grammys and all
that she has this dude
his name's q this black dude who
kind of like like she gets she does
coachella and but
as she's driving coachella she you're
you're like
so frustrated at her because this guy's
kind of a tool he looks like a dumbass
and she's just and she's 17. she's just
her first love how is it
she was 16. 16. he's probably 17. no
he's 22 at the time is he 22. he was 22
at the time oh that's time
yeah a lot of people came out after that
documentary because they looked him up
and then they're like wait why
i told him you told you told me about
you so you hear the tone of her voice
she got a paralegal tone in her voice
objection objection your honor
i didn't know that but what's
interesting what's interesting
is as i'm watching the doctor look at my
girl went i bet that dude q
is getting annihilated on social media
yes
because he's a dick like she's going to
coachella
she's headline coachella you know it's a
big [ __ ] deal
she's 16. and she's on the bus to
coachella and
you know they're passing billboards of
her album's about to drop
and you know she should be excited about
that she's calling having
drama with this dumb ass and she's like
are you going baby i love you and he's
like
you know we'll see acting all cool he's
i gotta see and he's like you know i'll
do that for you so
he gets there and she's like where's the
[ __ ] i haven't he said he's gonna hang
out with me i've seen him in two days he
took my vip passes
i haven't seen him in two days and then
finally
finally yeah probably sold him but then
finally they're in the green room
and you know she does her thing and
crushes on stage and gets back and she's
like
where where are you at and she's like no
i can't come to you like i'm
i can't leave the there's fans out there
she's like can you just please come here
and he's like nah you need to come to me
she's like i i can't i'm billy eilish
like i can't come
i'm like this dude i bet is about his
life's about to change and not for the
better man
how about that when i get off stage at
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son